others haven't and this has something to
do with the crisis in the you too many
in which spontaneously can't meet the Oh
in which we cooperate together is too
far too often national interests cannot
all bound to the interest cannot become
a melting a colorless melting Europe
lives and draws its diversity this is
the case the Commission does not intend
to get the nation-states destroy using
comfortable - you don't want to
undermine we want to comment we want
you're not convinced at issue not going
down the path nationalization it can
never become of fragmentation existence
where we need further afield from humor
and that is leaving scope for galloping
population lose and we cannot accept
that because Pope does not solve
problems on the country creates problems
and we have to
i smeared on each side and its really
high time we only take a clear look at
the situation unemployment continues to
be farting 20 million new jobs created
and employment is constantly rising but
social injustice continues and that have
to get to work on basis of social equity
energy side as well Europe is not social
enough we have to make that clear
this will understand in the dead in
Europe continues also to be at - higher
level we have seen a drop of deficit
rates 1.9 from 6.2 and so we don't want
to see a so that we don't break or
hinder think we also need to look into
the eyes of those who are observing us
from afar friends and partners worldwide
regrets it is the beginning of the
breakdown and disintegration process for
all European Union that we respect and
at the same time the European Union has
such events
here there on four valences political
outlets Gazoo we would be happy the
request for regs it could happen as
quickly as possible so that we can take
the specific effects which need to be
taken relations with the UK which the
internal market is still in a position
to enter into trade agreements with the
rest of the world in the world we have
trade agreements with 140 countries
worldwide a blind we cannot decide on
trade and trains in every seven I am
behind the trade agreement with Canada
it's the most progressive
the guarantees can be specified in the
very different ratification procedures
and we can rule out the concerns which
exist but we cannot in the US but in the
future in raising questions of climate
change is and it wouldn't have come into
being in the absence of the European
Union we are the pioneers we drove this
forward sometimes we also urged others
quite we are calling basic dragging and
feet on ratification undermine
international credibility links amongst
ourselves depend on this we're not in
any way the state of us and that's why
and difficult in national we have to
look different and they that we can be
fast and decisive on things that really
matter if we want a visa skirting who is
still to be severe
these cans I send em with this message
Prime Minister the Christ
and the boat and you that takes
responsibility to be part of this
European Union of this union of
Europeans to remember why European
nations chose to work together to
remember why Krauts celebrated
solidarity in the streets of awesome on
the 1st of May 2004 the date of
accession of this great polish nation
because Poland is a great nation
to remember why do you pin flag waves
proudly English boy or Porto Madrid and
Sevilla welcoming the young democracies
are Spain and Portugal in our sphere of
solidarity and freedom to remember that
Europe is a driving force that can help
bring about unification of Cyprus
something I am supporting the two
leaders of Cyprus in it has to be done
and it has to be done now
about all Europe means peace it is no
coincidence that the longest period of
peace in which Eastwind Europe started
with the formation of the European
communities 70 years of lasting peace in
Europe in a world with 40 active armed
conflicts which claimed the lives of two
hundred thousand people here after year
of course we still have our differences
sometimes we fight but we fight with
words and we settle our conflicts around
the table not in tranches an integral
part of our European Way of life is our
values the values the freedom democracy
the rule of law we Europeans can never
accept now Polish workers being harassed
beaten beaten up or even murdered in the
streets of Essex
we Europeans stand firmly against the
death penalty and we Europeans also
believe in independent effective justice
systems effective justice systems
support economic growth and defend from
the mantle rights
that is why Europe promotes and defends
the rule of law everywhere being
European means the right to have your
personal data protected by strong
European laws because Europeans do not
like the ones over at recording their
every move our company stockpiling the
every mouse-click this is why Parliament
council and Commission agreed in May
this year a common European data
protection in Europe privacy matters
European also means a fair playing field
this means that workers should get the
same pay for the same work in the same
place
and this is why the Commission stands
behind our proposal of the posting
workers directive the entire market is
not a place where workers can be
exploited or subjected to lower social
standards than others Europe is not the
Wild West but the social market economy
without social dumping a fair playing
field also means that in Europe
consumers are protected against Karthus
and abuses by powerful companies and
that every company no matter how big or
small has to pay its taxes where it
makes its profits
I was promising you that my commission
would fight against tax evasion and many
of you didn't believe me but that's what
we that's what we are doing we are
delivered this commission is delivering
on the fight against tax
being European also means standing up
for our steel industry we have already
have 37 anti-dumping intently subsidized
measures in place to protect our steel
industry from unfair competition but we
need to do more as overproduction in
some parts of the world is putting
European producers out of business
and the noble European steel workers out
of work this is why I was in China twice
this year to address the issue of over
capacity this is also why the Commission
has proposed to change the lesser Beauty
rule we call on all Member States and on
this Parliament to support the
Commission in strengthening our defense
instruments we should not be naive free
traders but be able to respond as
forcefully to dumping as the United
States of America are doing it's wrong
part of the European Way of life I want
to preserve is our agricultural sector
the Commission will always stand by our
files particularly when they go through
difficult moment as is the case today
last year the dairy sector was hit with
a ban imposed by Russia this is why the
Commission mobilised 1 billion euro in
support the milk farmers to help them
back on their feet because I will not
accept that milk is cheaper than water
being European for most of us also means
do during the global financial crisis do
states wrong and protected us from even
worse instability do is a leading well
country and it brings huge often
invisible economic benefits you who area
countries saved 50 billion you was
disappear in interest payments thanks to
the European Central Bank's Monetary
Policy fifty billion extra that
governments can intrude invest into the
economy fifty billion that can be used
for debt reduction and by the way the
five presidents report on the deepening
of your area describes an ambition the
Commission is still sticking to I wish
all this was recalled more often
everywhere in New York where elected
politicians take the floor European
Union should not only preserve our
European way of life but empower those
living it we need to work for Europe
that empowers our citizens and our
economy and today both have gone digital
digital technologies and digital
communications are going into every
aspect of life all they require is
access to high-speed Internet we need to
be connected our economy needs it people
need it and we have to invest in that
connectivity now that is why today the
Commission is proposing a reform for our
European telecommunication markets we
want to create a new legal framework
that the tracks and enables investments
in connectivity businesses should be
able to plan their investments in Europe
for the next 20 years
because if you pians invest in new
networks and services that is at least
1.3 million new jobs over the next
decade and connectivity should antennae
fit everyone that is why the Commission
is proposing a fully deployed 5g across
European Union by 2025 this has the
potential to create further 2 million
jobs in European everyone benefiting
from connectivity means that it will not
matter where you live and how much you
earn so we propose today to equip every
European values and every city with real
wireless internet access around the main
centers of public life by 2020 as the
world goes digital we have also to
empower our artists and creators and
protect their works artists and creators
our crown jewels the creation of content
is not a hobby it is a profession I want
journalists publishers authors to be
paid fairly for their work whether it is
made in studios or living rooms whether
this disseminated offline online whether
it is published via a copying machine or
hyperlinked on the web the overall field
copyright rules we are proposing today
does exactly that
empowering our European economy means
investing not just in connectivity but
in job creation the 350 billion
investment plan for Europe which we
agreed here has already raised 160
billions in investments in this first
year of operation over 200,000 small
teams firms and startups across Europe
got lumps thanks to the European fund
for strategic investments and now we'll
take it further
today we propose to double the duration
of the fund and to double its financial
capacity with your support we'll make
sure that our European investment fund
will provide the total of at least 500
billion half a trillion of investments
by 2020 and we will work beyond that to
reach six six hundred and thirty billion
by 2020 true of course with member
states contributing we can get there
even faster along these efforts to
attract private investments we also need
to create the right environment to
invest in European banks in a much
better shape than two years ago thanks
to our joint European efforts Europe
needs its banks but the economy almost
entirely dependent on banquet credit is
Bank for financial stability and it is
bad for business as we saw during the
financial crisis that is why it is now
urgent we accelerate our work on the
capital markets Union the Commission is
proposing is putting a concrete road map
for this on your table today a capital
markets union will make our financial
system by far more resilient
it will give companies easier and more
diversified access to finance
imagine you run startup and your bank
refuses you alone right now the options
are very limited the capital markets
Union will offer alternative vital
sources of funding to help startup get
started business angels venture capital
market financing to just mention one
example our proposal on secularization
has been on the table of the colleges
letters for all me almost one in our it
has the potential winning up to 100
billion years of additional finance for
European businesses so let us please
speed up its adoption our investment
plan work better than anyone expected
inside Europe and now we are going to
take it global today we are launching an
invest in ambitious investment plan for
Africa and the neighborhood which has
the potential to waste 44 billion in
investments it can go up to 88 billion
if members let's pitch in this will
complement our development aid and help
address one of the root causes of
migration with economic growth in
developing countries at its lowest level
since 2003
this is crucial the new plan will offer
lifelines for those who would otherwise
be pushed to take dangerous journeys in
search of a better life it has to be
as much as we invest in improving
conditions of what we also need to
invest in responding to humanitarian
crises back home and more than anything
we need to invest in our young people I
cannot and will not accept that who is
and remains the continent of youth
unemployment I cannot and will not
accept that millions I will not accept
that the Generation Y might be the first
generation in 70 years to be poorer than
their parents of course this is mainly a
task of national governments you are not
a part of I know dot European Union can
support this effort and their efforts we
are doing this with the European youth
guarantee that was launched three years
ago the Commission enhanced the
effectiveness and sped up delivery on
youth and youth guarantee more than nine
million young people who got a job
traineeship or apprenticeship because of
the European Union and we will continue
to roll out the youth guarantee across
Europe mainly as far as advertisers are
concerned improving the skill set of
Europeans and reaching out to the
regions and young people most in need
European Union can also contribute to
helping create opportunities for young
people so a many young socially minded
young people in Europe willing to make a
meaningful contribution to society and
third so solidarity the word solidarity
appears 16 times in the treaties
the European our European budget is a
living proof a financial solidarity you
is an expression of solidarity and our
development policy is a strong external
sign of solidarity and when it comes to
managing the refugee crisis we have
started to see solidarity I'm convinced
much more solidarity is needed by also
know that solidarity must be voluntary
it must come from the heart it cannot be
forced
it cannot be imposed I'm urging the
Slovak presidency to which the
divergences and differences between
those who are reluctant to integrate
refugees in their societies and those
who are convinced as I am that the fair
share in relocation and resettlement is
of the essence
I am asking a strong and immediate
action both from Greece and European
Union to protect what we call in French
liaison for normal compa normal company
without protection of this children
European Union is betraying its historic
values in the same spirit the Commission
is proposing today to set up a European
solidarity cog young people across
European Union will be able to volunteer
their help where it is needed most to
respond to crisis situations like
refugee crisis or the recent earthquakes
in Italy I want this European solidarity
core up and running as soon as possible
and by 2020 to see the first 100,000
young Europeans taking part by voluntary
joining the European solidarity core
this young people will be able to
develop their skills and get not only
work but also an invaluable human
experience
Monsieur president president president
council Europe is a Europe itself both
inside and outside its borders need and
this is a priority to do this to
counterterrorism as of 2004 Europe has
suffered more than 30 terrorist attacks
14 have happened over the past year we
all maintained solidarity throughout our
suffering and mourning we must to take a
collective approach to this we must be
truthful and faithful to ourselves or to
values to our multicultural society we
need to show terrorists that they have
no chance when they try to attack these
tolerance which cannot fly in the face
of our safety and security and that's
why the Commission at the outset has
given up special systems - for the
return of and we are combating the
financing of terrorism we are using the
internet to combat terrorist propaganda
and we are combating radicalization in
prisons and elsewhere but we still have
a lot of work to do and we must don't
know which individuals are crossing our
borders and it is for this reason that
we defend with a new special
frontex
agency there are agents in Greece at the
border with Turkey and we have more than
a hundred agents in Bulgarian the Member
States and the institution's must work
closely in order to make sure that we
can set up this new agency I would like
to see the deployment as of October of
200 border guards and 50 additional
vehicles at the border with Bulgaria we
will also defend our borders in terms of
those will be very strict as to who can
cross the borders and this is something
that we are looking to implement by the
end of the year anyone coming into the
European Union or leaving the European
Union will be registered will have to
date the place and the reason as to why
new information system a travel
information system which will be
automated we will be able to determine
who is who have the right to travel into
Europe so in this way we'll see who will
be travelling into Europe but before
that person even arrives on our
territory the security of our borders
means that we have to give a priority to
the exchange of information and
intelligence and so we are strengthening
Europol to this end because we giving
greater access to databases that and
giving them the necessary means to carry
out their work and this is what has to
be in line with our ambitions Europe
that also should outside its borders the
world is getting a little bigger every
day and the and Europe is getting
smaller every day demographically and
economically
if we wish to maintain our influence in
the world it is that we have to work
together and it is together that we will
be able to face challenges if Europe is
being a soft power we have to admit that
this is not sufficient in a world that
is ever more dangerous let's look at the
conflict in Syria as an example the
consequences for Europe of this conflict
are immediate but where is the Union
where are the Member States in the
negotiations to try to solve this
conflict mogherini the Commission is
doing a remarkable travel that's not
just my opinion but what we need is a
European Minister of Foreign Affairs
this is something that should be similar
selkies although something that should
will bring together national diplomatic
forces in order to weigh in in
international negotiations this is why
I'm asking us to draw up a should have a
seat to the negotiating table on the
future of Syria should take a stronger
point of view in terms of our defense we
can no longer depend singular power of
individuals all the states together we
have to make sure that we we have 30
military and civil missions carried out
by the European Union but we don't have
a permanent structure and without that
we're not able to work efficiently
we must a European headquarters
new technologies oriented and so work
towards a common military force and this
should be in complement with NATO in
Europe doesn't mean less transatlantic
solidarity bringing together military
resources could be justified and that is
something which is very useful because
the lack of cooperation is something
which is costing the European Union 20
to 100 billion a year so we must do
something in this area in order to
guarantee the Solidarity its innovation
reason European Defense Fund to actively
stimulate research and innovation in
this area the Lisbon Treaty allowance
member states to do so to make their
capacity available through and I think
it's high time to me to avail ourselves
of this possibility to do with our
collective responsibility and I'm
calling on all of the European Union
institutions and each of the member
states to assume because we cannot
survive without working together needs
be better explained and I asked the
commissioners over the coming weeks to
visit national parliaments in order to
Commission to national parliaments more
than three times and I'd like for them
to do that
you understood it has to be better
explained it can only be built with the
Member States not the Member States and
so the Commission is the Commission
which gives rise to strange ideas but
the Commission needs to therefore the
citizens we need to listen to the
citizens we need to listen to Member
States and we do listen to our citizens
and we would like to do that more
intensely sometimes I really did that
the in their ivory towers at family more
and don't want to listen to others some
people I'm not listening to others but
to those who think that are taken to the
European citizens because this is my
duty this is everyone's duty we have
reduced the number of initiatives and we
are reviewing all of the legislation in
because we need to focus on the areas in
which Europe that can give us eight
valuing this is the only way in which we
can make Europe a space of subsidary and
solidarity and solidarity and any
mission that we would have to correct
any technical errors that may the
Commission has done away with roaming
for roaming charges for and that's why
we are good intentions behind doing away
with these roaming charges it was very
good in terms of that the technicalities
and next week you will see a new draft
which is when you travel in Europe with
your mobile phone you will be able to
feel at home anywhere in Europe thanks
to take responsibility for our actions
these VR citizens and that's why I would
like to change this to the third year
that we have the we must encourage the
commissioners to live up to democracy
and and as young as the European project
which is celebrating 60 years
the next year in March maybe a little
bit older and so I've experienced all of
this I've lived it through this project
and I've dedicated my entire life to
this I've done this from conviction and
I have not hesitated stability in the
continent and work and social progress
my father believed in this as well and
he knew how Europe was and how it was
because he had to live through the war
he had to fight in the war against
country and my father instilled in me
these values and what are we instilling
in terms of value to our children what
is the heritage is are we giving them is
this a union that has forgotten its past
that has no vision for the future
gentlemen our children deserve better
they deserve in Europe their way of life
which champions that way of life and
protects it and so it's high time for us
the citizens and the institutions and
the government responsibilities Europe
and to build it together yes that there
are certain debates so when we talk
about the future of Europe there's some
optimist and then there are the but I
think Europe has a mission and you have
the pessimism which only looks at a
default set and then you have the rosy
for you those who will not give up work
in the spirit of love for future
generations and
and that is the result of those who came
before us and calling on us to have
resolved so that we can get over our
differences the history will not remain
remember our names we will be remembered
by the force of our resolve and our
convictions and so this needs to be
integrated the history will not remember
the history will remember our mistakes
and will make us responsible for
peel danke Schon president that's what
them kids but in fact sooner VP during
the brexit debate I spoke about the
young generation in Great Britain they
wanted to belong to Europe again today I
want to speak about the young generation
they had a great summer I have to say
over a quarter of a million of
youngsters demonstrated their love of
Europe this summer they took the trains
with inter rail they did not fuel
mistrust say made friends with other
European youth instead journalists from
the German weekly - piggle interviewed
some of these young people one of them
was a young Britain aimed chain he said
yes we voted to remain and it feels
terrible to be out for Europe's youth
Europe is he hope for a better future a
young Italian named Matteo was asked
which European nationality can you not
stand which country should not be part
of the European Union and listened his
answer was none of course what a stupid
question